Speaker 1: Hey, this is really funny. Bill
O'Reilly sort of trying to make a comeback after
being completely disgraced. On Fox News last week,
Bill O'Reilly played up his anger where he sort of
like is frustrated with his scripts and looks at
pretending to rip them up. And he was flipping out
because of minorities and gang violence and who
the hell knows what? He now is offering a service.
It's a concierge program where if you have travel
questions for Bill, if you have a problem with a
product or an airline. Has stiffed you or left
you high and dry at an airport or whatever.
You can contact Bill and he will give you advice.
And this is what I should be doing this, shouldn't
I? Anyway. Tell me if this sounds appealing
to you or if this is just the latest grift.
Speaker 4: So I get a lot of questions about
people traveling the world. Yep. And I. Because
I've been to 84 countries, I can steer you into
good places and tell you if you get ripped off.
Speaker 1: Is it really worth paying? €12
a day to rent a bike in Copenhagen. You
don't know. And you're in Copenhagen
and you're like, is this a good price? You
contact Bill O'Reilly and he will tell you.
Speaker 4: That questions about consumer
problems that somebody contractors do an A
and then I can steer them. I get financial
questions. I cannot give financial or medical
advice, but I can tell you what I would do.
Speaker 1: Right. If you're like, listen, Bill,
I know you can't tell me whether I
should open a 529 account for my kid
or whether interest rates are going. I
know you can't officially tell me, but
what would you do in this exact same situation?
Speaker 4: All right so life is complicated for
a concierge membership on Bill O'Reilly dot
com you have me. To answer your questions,
which we do within 24 hours right now.
Speaker 1: Who is we? Is that the royal we?
I don't know what that is. That's interesting.
Speaker 4: I mean, it's pretty amazing.
So you might want to think about it.
Speaker 1: Yeah, definitely something to think
about. Now, you might be shocked to hear this.
It's only $7.92 a month for this. So my belief
is that Bill O'Reilly isn't personally
answering your questions for 792 a month.
My guess is that it's some lackey. So, you
know, I'm considering a new espresso machine.
Maybe it's time for me to go and ask Bill
O'Reilly. What? What about which steam ones are
the best? Do I need a double boiler? He's the guy.
He's the guy that I guess I should be asking. Now,
in all seriousness, I don't know how many people
have checked out Bill O'Reilly's content recently.
It's pretty weird. Like it seems almost like
a kind of neutered Bill O'Reilly who has to
pretend and play up his anger. I'll I'll
play a little bit of this stuff for you.
Here is the no spin news from from O'Reilly.
Check this out. Oh, no, hold on. Sorry. It's
actually hard. They make it hard to find previews.
Let's see if I can even navigate his Web site. No
spin news. Watch free excerpts. Let's see if we
can check that out. Um. He hears a segment about
Hunter Biden that he did yesterday. This should
be interesting. Let's check out his commentary.
Speaker 4: It doesn't seem like the Hunter Biden
situation. It's two years since a grand jury has
been impaneled in. In Delaware. It doesn't take
two years to do this kind of investigation. So
I'm saying that this is just phony.
Speaker 1: This whole. Now,
does it mean that it's phony to even
be investigating him or that the
investigation is a cover.
Speaker 4: All Hunter
Biden thing? How do you see it?
Speaker 3: Yeah. The concern I have,
Bill, is when you have already put witnesses
in front of the grand jury, you're supposed to
request that the grand jury, once they've heard
from all the witnesses, to vote on whether or
not to indict and and they put witnesses many,
many months ago in front of the grand jury.
So the question really is, do they ever intend to?
Because I've never seen it take this long from the
time they had witnesses in front of the grand.
Speaker 1: I guess they're saying that the
Hunter investigation is a sham.
That seems to be the point to win.
Speaker 3: The prosecutor says, okay, you have the
case now, grand jury now go and vote on whether
or not an indictment should come.
Speaker 4: Yeah, the prosecutors,
a guy named David Weiss, Delaware U.S.
attorney. But this looks phony to me.
Speaker 1: All right. So there's below that. So
if you're looking for Hunter Biden takes there is
an interesting one. Let's see if I can find oh,
he oh, this has to be this is going to be good
here. Bill provides advice if you go to
breakfast at a diner, how to save some money.
Speaker 4: So it's really bad in America now.
It'll get better, but it's going to be a while
and we're going to be absorbing pain.
Speaker 1: I. I can't. I'm.
The idea of bill o'reilly giving dinner
advice. I am so curious what he says.
Speaker 4: I his import provides you with
security. It provides you with peace of mind.
Don't waste money.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 4: So I'm going to give you tips
under the Smart Life banner to save money.
Okay. We do it two times a week. We'll have a
lot of tips on the website. If you have tips,
please send it to us and share it with the rest of
the world. Yeah look Bill O'Reilly dot com again
let us all we'll post okay so over the week I
took the urchins for breakfast about I don't know
quarter of a mile from my house and he.
Speaker 1: Took that he took the
urchins. What is that like? His grandkids.
Speaker 4: They go in and they immediately
they order $2.50 orange juice. Oh, okay.
Speaker 1: And Bill's only worth 85 million,
so he's not going to stand for that.
Speaker 4: So, little cop 250
Tropicana. I saw them pour it. Not fresh
squeaks. Okay. Today I went on the Internet
and 56, 58 ounces of Tropicana. Three bucks.
Speaker 1: Oh, this. I don't. This is the most
compelling thing I've ever. This is the most
interesting TV Bill O'Reilly has ever done.
Speaker 4: So my urging spent five bucks on
little cups when you could get 58 ounces and
we have it in the refrigerator.
Speaker 1: Now, I wonder if Bill
O'Reilly drinks wine at restaurants,
because it's hard to find something
more overpriced than that. I mean, this is weird.
Speaker 4: We have it. So, look, time to go. What
are you doing? We have O.J. in a refrigerator.
What? What? What is this? Five bucks on fire.
Then they order their entrees, what they
want for breakfast. And then they order a
side of corned beef hash. Oh. Now the side
of corned beef hash in a place is good,
but they didn't want to change the menu prices, so
they cut the size in half. It's nine bucks. Why?
You should get a pretty good portion of Gorbachev.
Speaker 1: Bill is not getting his corned
beef hash and he is pissed.
Speaker 4: You don't any longer.
And then eliminate it.
Speaker 1: This this seems like satire.
This this seems like it is a joke.
Speaker 4: We're far from the pancakes
and the omelet. Sitting here going. All right,
let's set it up. Nine bucks and five bucks.
14 bucks you just set on fire.
Speaker 1: I think Bill's tip
is order less food when you go out, eat
less. Food is really the way to save money.
Speaker 4: And again. And now
the eyeroll is the eyeroll. Oh,
now. Okay. This is what I'm talking about. The
origins of the old blank in Clue. They work. They
have to in my house. But Dad pays the breakfast.
Speaker 1: Oh, I guess he's talking about his
kids, not even his grandkids.
Speaker 4:
But it's that kind of way.
You've got to be thinking about
value. You got to be thinking about this now.
Speaker 1: There's two layers of this first.
Hearing Bill O'Reilly be pissed off about the
size of a corned beef beef corned beef hash side
is endlessly fascinating. I actually might pay for
it. I'm now thinking I might buy the subscription
and send questions about pizza toppings and how to
save money and you know, have them calculate the
area of a circle to tell us that the larger pizza
is usually the better deal. That's fascinating.
But this is kind of like the Latin millionaire
stuff. This is a big thing in the personal finance
space, which is like, hey, listen, you know, if
you just didn't get your your latte every day,
you'd be a millionaire. You know, in like 17 years
you'll be a millionaire or whatever. You know,
the reality is that the things that for most
people are keeping them from being financially
independent or even stable. Right. They're just
just even stable. Ah, the cost of housing, cost of
transportation, stagnant wages. It's not like it's
fine. This stuff is fine, but it's along the same
lines of get rich by sipping coffee. And it's not
really representative of the financial pressure
that that is on most people. But there it is. Bill
O'Reilly, fascinating, fascinating stuff there.